where did we leave off oh hey guys what
I learned a thing in the interim that
really would have really helped us with
the situation we've got going on with
the levels okay you know how you had to
you know how you put all those vertical
supports around yeah stay in the full
release of the game made it so you could
just put horizontal supports no no this
this is what I said in the last episode
I was like I learned about horizontal
supports guys did you know you can build
horizontal foundations and you don't
need to put pillars everywhere
yeah I could redo I'll go back I'll go
back oh wait but think about what you're
gonna destroy yeah no no no no it's fine
this is the Gazebo it raft all over
again no no it's not it's not yes yes
yes it am you mean the gazebo in the
forest yeah wait what did I say the red
you said gazebo and raft although I
would like to make a gazebo I thought
you intentionally said it because he was
the gazebo in raft but uh
I was giving you credit there but I
guess two points to mark that well thank
you did they get rid of the ability to
turn the engines on and off at the
steering wheel uh
uh yes
and I'm five inches away from the engine
but but oh that's probably glad we put
it right there next to it that's why we
cooked that's why we did that I thought
we did anyway but I have to look at it
stop
or is it better or worse that it's
easier now
I don't know man look Life's real tough
for all of us and it's gonna be okay
except that it's not okay
yeah are you sure it's gonna be okay
because I'm so that's pretty sus
honestly I have no idea I just show up
yep same for us and we and all of
everyone now land hoes Lando what are we
looking for right now we got bees going
right are we coordinated puffer fish
right we need puffer fish so we can get
more animals for the things we need from
animals yeah they we get wool from uh
the Llama from Lomi
um I have shears I can try steering it
yeah I've got shoes too I've been
cheering pretty regularly but also feel
free if you see a shareable opportunity
go for it we need to research wool still
we need to research wool titanium and
eggs yeah let me let me go and Pop I
think it's in my yeah I have it
we haven't been able to get eggs yet
because whoa hey armor nice yes
nice a backpack oh my god oh really
I'm assuming that's what the backpack is
for right oh where is backpack there it
is it expands your inventory he needs
six wool four leather and four rope oh
in theory we should have plenty of
leather we cut a lot of bears yeah we
did um where did the leather get to the
storage is kind of in disarray at the
moment what I don't know what you're
talking about
oh
I thought dropping anchor nothing oh
nothing bad is gonna happen I thought we
might crash yeah what if the boat
shattered on land that'd be awesomely
awful that'd be so sick dude we got so
much fuel so sick Bro I forgot that we
actually got fuel working this is dope
do we have a lot of fuel it's full it
feels full because you piped it in and
it's been cooking up I think it's full
but so you have to fill the thing on top
right the the tank on the engine should
always be full but this tank up top
right right right okay so this jar here
you just pick up and then when it's done
I guess you just pick it up and you put
it in there that's the thing okay okay
all right well we currently have 31
leather
in one of these checks hell yeah okay we
need more chess yeah bro uh where did my
honey there it is we do have a lot of
honey I guess I'm gonna take all the
beets and potatoes Mark and those are
good for fuel yes they are good for fuel
I have a stack in my inventory to plant
new ones which I need to get going do
you oh yeah how many do you need to
plant I don't need that many I've got a
stack of both I'm good you can shove
those all in okay I'm gonna take all
these beets and potatoes here and
they're still 20 beats and 19 potatoes
in one of the food chests but I'm gonna
put these bad boys in the biofuel
thingies we should either kill the shark
or bait because we need to go around and
look for uh puffer fish yeah we need
more of that so we can make more Nets
well I wasn't fishing so I don't have
anything to make bait I'm gonna rely on
you guys for that hey
uh shark attacking is it are you sure I
got it I got it but you left without
preparing this it looked pretty bad oh
yeah whatever I built a third step I
built the third star you guys can cut me
some slack you're right you're right
disagree minus two points what you seem
to be what are you talking about points
I don't know I just like points what are
these Point things you keep talking
about I'm gonna
can we do our organization yes please
that would be amazing please okay I am
gonna try and use an empty inventory
here
to just just reconfigurate some stuff
hey Blowfish maybe I'm not going out far
enough uh the Blowfish don't necessarily
exist at like every island yeah
we might need to go to a good Island
like the next spot if I'm remembering
has maybe Blowfish maybe the last one
did but we didn't take any time looking
for him I know it did they've done it
before he's he's baiting oh he's not
beaten anymore
you're fine you're fine you're fine
you're fine you're fine you're fine stop
complaining am I fine yeah of course
you're fine he's back he's a baby he's
baiting another storm over there
well there's nothing besides underwater
materials together here wait we need
clay right this place up we still need
more of always
we need all all of the everything most
of the time uh was that a reference to
Bo Burnham's uh welcome to the internet
uh let's say yes
what a show I love that show good good
good do we have wood perhaps per chance
uh yes we do yeah there's a whole bunch
of one of the chest I need oxygen
I'm in a cave
here do you have flippers yet nope this
guy doesn't even have flippers I am
making the organization wall I love that
I love it there's a shark in my cave
whoa you can put him on the wall yes you
can oh that's so cool you're so cool
genius I am oh God you're so cool God
thank you God tell me more oh God I wish
I was half as cool as you a third even
too bad you're not being eaten by the
shark man ah do you hear something dude
[Laughter]
sorry uh yeah
I actually didn't hear anything actually
which way is the island
right under the boat Bob where you want
clay
uh I did I haven't touched that yet
I'll figure it out forever
That's my kind of placement that's what
he do
oh hey a shark eating the boat man
oh wow that bait really did not last
very long
oh my God guys I'm I'm starving to death
but with water what's that called hmm
drowning but without I'm the opposite of
drowning
I don't know what that is oh God he's
weaning why is there a sail on the top
is this supposed to be up here I just
put it there first oh okay I had that
and I was like what the hell we don't
want to sail get out of here I was
looking at I was like I don't remember
there being a sale here but maybe I'm
stupid wow how am I supposed to organize
all the random crap we have in this game
honestly I don't know but when you
volunteered I was very happy
good luck I mean yeah yeah we all know a
ghost you know what I mean honestly I
know about gauche you don't need to tell
me about it I don't is that like Zool
what
yes I guess and we're going with yes
there's a lot of clay and sand out here
so it's a good time to stock up on it I
forget what we needed a bunch of clay
for but I know we needed it we always
need clay oh god oh I have no Health oh
no rip R.I.P bro I'll be back and I'm
alive rip bro oh hey ass face I had clay
to put in that wrong chest just put it
in somewhere I'm working on it it's
gonna it's a whole process right now
okay these things obviously go together
yeah it's good
most good emotions
yes where's uh do you can I steal some
scrap metal not metal metal but scrap
metal somewhere in the it hasn't been
organized yet
under the raft it's okay I got I got a
guy I just need to make some scare Crews
some skirkers where the shark went
what if I get bit once I'm dead
well he's probably ate some food that we
definitely have
huh
what the hell is happening
no I got you I'm with you all right cool
yeah no do you fear death though
do you feel deaf
[Laughter]
I need to kill this shark so I can
freely Harvest materials
hey Mark I bet you can't kill this shark
you're probably right
good to know my limits you always took a
challenge
you know what it Mark has spent so long
pushing his limits he's found them
exactly he knows what his body can and
cannot handle and he can't handle that
oh
weeping is the first stage of acceptance
so I've heard oh
fine is that singing or oh yeah singing
a lullaby I call it the Sharks on my ass
what's new Sharky cat oh
you make me laugh
all right how's the organization coming
I hate it it's very slow don't worry
about it good good good to hear good to
hear we're doing well on getting the uh
new washing machine
um sorry what yeah there he is he's
coming
would it help you if I like made another
bait or something or
or may may hops which is a word I don't
know that's real but Mark said it so I
say it now I'm pretty sure that's a word
why would that not be rude uh sharks
just destroyed a big important plank by
the end I don't believe it
well okay I choose not to believe you I
have no wood but I will stare at this
plank and will it back into existence
yeah you stare at that think about what
you did what you done
begged for help with the sharks then
destroyed our boat that's what I did
think about what you've done I need
plastic
Bob need plastic
need plaid son of a [ __ ] oh did you
build the wrong one after all that you
would maybe maybe
God oh damn it you know I'm committed at
this point so I'm probably dead oh God
and I'm out of spear
you doing great pal
keep it up buddy we have an extra
cooking pot Mark do you need that uh no
we only really got space for one and
it's already got soup that's been
waiting for a clay Bowl forever we got
some clay hey I got mango seeds down
here do you need that uh I'm gonna go
with no Yes actually yes also there's 20
raw meat down here literally just
chilling
it's pretty cool mango seeds are in one
of the last unorganized boxes that is
great I will be right down to get it as
soon as I figure out my uh emergency
hunger situation I have a bunch of crap
that doesn't belong here but I'm gonna
drop it in this chest did you just fill
up the one I was emptying to move
trying to get it empty so I can pick it
up wait if you're on if it's the chest
you're touching then no I put it in this
one over here oh thank God okay
I think you're fine I think I'm I think
I'm inappropriately angry at you an
iPhone okay good because yeah I couldn't
even open the one you were in I wasn't
in it when you were talking so I wasn't
uh okay well I saw you were in one so I
went to another one I was like oh hey
this was like a random assortment [ __ ]
let me add some [ __ ]
I appreciate that hey Mark your crops
are getting absolutely [ __ ] on right
now no they're not it's a skirkra
why are you in so much denial today this
denial day
[Laughter]
that joke made me happy but it should
have made me sad why would have made you
sad
I don't know because it sounds like what
I would have made that no one loves that
we all left that makes me sad I'm sorry
buddy oh you're welcome I'm so sad for
you are we friendshiping right
okay I couldn't tell you yeah who knows
really it's a mystery one of the
Mysteries of the world at least we're
doing it our way
there's a cave here I don't know if
there's dirt in it but there's a cave
here and I don't have a shovel if there
is dirt I had there's a shovel in one of
the storage boxes that's not it's the
bottom right one oh I'm way too not oh
that's not a shovel that's a paddle well
I guess you could typically use a shovel
as a paddle but not in this air paddle
you could
keep going you got it
no no I was just gonna I'm making
another water thing so we can constantly
have a okay good because I'm not saying
that I'm hiding the mango seeds from you
but I'm not not saying that I'm hiding
the mango seeds from you interesting I'm
it's like a nebulous state of
Schrodinger's mangoes uh-huh uh-huh
right yeah all right okay I'm hearing
you I'm hearing you I found a new recipe
for simple fish stew bet we don't have
that one
well you don't need to be so pessimistic
about it we don't or we do but shut up
it's it's kind of a Schrodinger's recipe
of
we do wait what is the recipe alive in
the box or dead in the Box oh only one
way to find out
oh thank you rain
thank you rain for watering our crops I
thought you were thinking like someone
for cheering bits thank you rain for the
new sub thank you Rain Korean pop star
from the uh late Audis
still relevant as some might say still
relevant is that a weird way to say the
80s no no that's like that oh the zero
double o's
what you don't need to understand it
fully just accept it
okay guys I think you're gonna really
love slash not understand my
organizational scheme and I'm excited
for it
well if I'm being honest
I think Wade's having some kind of
trouble yeah or he's enjoying himself
oh is that the Shark Wave you got a
friend I don't know there's no
confirmation that it was the shark it
could have been anything really Philly
confirms whether it saves me it was the
shark
I'm not sure I'm dead right next to the
boat
uh I think the thing
she's fine yeah I heard fine I need help
I'm literally not fine nothing could be
worse please help me
I'm not sure couldn't be more clear
about this need rescued
oh God I'm thirsty Mark I'm gonna hang
on I need to take care of this there's
plenty of water around so feel free grab
wherever you can that's true it's true
it's true you're right
me
hey Wade do you need help yeah
yes what does that mean
what he figured it out
thank you if I put a roof over these
plants is it gonna legit affect would
would a bird not get it
would not do anything oh they don't give
a [ __ ] about your roof I'm not sure fair
enough I need some signs Lads do you
ever just just need some signs signs I
don't know what that is how do we not
have scrap oh we have a small amount of
scrap I have 20 on me where I've been
Gathering it and dying to the shark
would you like it no I got it I got
enough for what I'm doing
okay what's this what's this I think you
made a thing what's this what's this A
PPP ping I started so strong
I didn't know what rhymed with the thing
oh well you got it PPP Pig
and argue with that that is that's
pretty accurate did you get a blowfish
no there are none here oh wow that's the
foreign
[Music]
can I steal some clay you burn [ __ ]
I'll kill you
can I steal some clay here have eight oh
thank you I'm just gonna make some bowls
there's more clay in a box somewhere I
just can make bowls so we can get soup
going again
all right this is how we're doing this
apparently yep yep that's fine this is
how we're doing this
apparently
that's what I'm here for that's what I
live for thank you I love that I like it
when you're funny thank you thank you I
found a really bad candid button it
really did yeah I was trying to let's
see genuinely it just didn't sound like
I did it hurt but you know I tried to
smile through the pain
that was me begging you for help while I
was dying in the water when were you
dying oh we would have helped you oh man
recently
that doesn't seem right I think you're
lying we would have definitely helped
you
we got double the cooking capacity boys
hell yeah price the soup
hey get off our boat
oh he's dead oh good oh my God died I'll
cook him up
man why did he give you trouble wait he
died pretty quick well I was stabbing
the [ __ ] of him while he murdered me if
only I'd had a friend help him maybe he
would have died faster I don't know
I don't know about that one Bob how you
feel about Shark Heads they're good for
stew I'll put it up with food I have 11
of them down here we're low on scrap
metals yeah we only have a bit left
there's a lot of it in the water near
you guys if you want to jump in and grab
some while there's no shark oh man God I
would
thank you
God busy
boys we made it hell yeah
what did we make it it I love it this is
it love it
love it some other words
I love that song it's my favorite God I
remember it like it was yesterday I
can't just leave it hanging I have to
fill in the blanks with something uh-huh
let my brain be
why don't you go get some Blowfish I'm
I'm broke the blow but I can't find it
how do we make never mind shut up go
away who are you how'd you get on my
boat
you got so much biofuel you we are
loaded with biofuel our engines are just
so soaked
excellent
so we're biodegradable
yeah
oh my God guys there's not going to be
signs I'm bailing on the signs
fine signs no where are there signs [ __ ]
[ __ ] something that rhymes I wish there
was a way to put signs on chests you
know
yes you know I'm in full
meant with you
I'm gonna throw away All These
Blueprints we have all right well the
stuff is not any more organized than it
maybe was before but it's all much
easier to look at so we got that going
forward good that's great see these
things that's the one that contains
stuff that goes in the filters blade
does not go in the smelters so clay goes
in the far left one clearly I see of
course right clearly and sand sand goes
in the smeltables that's true really
clearly
seaweed does too
clearly clearly uh I took it out because
the smeltables one is small and the
metals are more important so the system
works but it's arbitrary and changes at
a whim is great don't look at it don't
look at the system never look at the
system why did you throw a recipe for
simple fish stew I thought we were
throwing out recipes we didn't need
anymore put it in the trash wait wait
wait I do not see a recipe on my board
for simple fish stew oh okay well I've
got it over here
you monster I literally called it out I
was told we had it already uh put it on
this well I assumed you were dumb so
there you go happy birthday oh guys I'm
so thirsty right now uh can't help you
why are both of the waters down here
empty oh wait come on oh I have never
come on in the history of us doing this
gotten water back up he's never failed
to be heard him first I will murder you
if you sleep
yeah you see he's kind of it's kind of
hostile he is kind of our style you're
right thank you I've been working on it
anyway there's so much uh uh soup
cooking up you guys will be pleasantly
surprised slurprised if you ask me
I don't know what that was I think your
body just shuddering at my my attempted
humor and I get that
I get it I get it I understand where do
you want clams hinges and Nails clams
has one you got a clam chest oh I mean
are there other things and there's one
us one of the small ones has hinges
nails and bolts in it as well as slime
goo which is really where that goes all
right see see this is there's a system
and slime goo
yeah no that one that's a mistake
let's go ahead and put that elsewhere
yeah don't look at the Slime whatever
you do don't look at the Slime I look
directly at it oh god oh no we're so
good guys we're so set right now God
we're set oh the water is drinkable oh
good I think we've harvested everything
under the water here that's to begotten
good work us do we need to cut down any
trees or anything or we don't need that
stuff anymore uh all the trees on the
island would not be a bad thing to have
yeah I have all right some of the last
wood we actually one of you ax boys uh I
get it I can get out there he's going
well I need help underwater you're both
busy I need help with a tree you both
are like oh man not danger okay don't
help him Bob turn back you heard him he
doesn't need it I never needed the wood
you guys need wood you guys do things I
just show up sounds like somebody's
taking a lot of things for granted yes
you guys are you should be more thankful
for me Soups On guys scrap and bolt
scrap and bolt what do we need we need
scrap and bolt by Parker Brothers am I
what who's that Parker Brothers
do they exist in this universe they
probably did no they're dead oh god well
I don't know what both of them why am I
astonished like oh not the Parker
Brothers No is it everyone that's not on
this route anyone should have survived
it should have been those that bring joy
though they were the first to go eaten
by their own kind uh who what they're
kind they woke Daddy and Daddy was
pissed oh no I think God I don't like
that I don't know if anyone knows the
board game Don't Wake Daddy no one does
how would anyone know that oh hey a
shark's eating that board that we
replaced gosh darn it hmm
you know what I mean if you feel me if
you feel you know oh leaving world oh
the darkness has consumed me oh I'm in
the back rooms now